this is Jocko podcast number 159 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
there's a a terrible feeling in the gut
that I've only felt while I was overseas
in Iraq and it's it's this deeply
distressed kind of sick feeling and it
literally feel it in your gut literally
feel it in your stomach in my stomach
and it's not it's not the fear it's not
fear it's not it's not the fear of death
because when you get to a point when you
kind of accept that death is a
possibility and you're okay with it then
that fear kind of goes away and it's not
the fear of one of your guys being
wounded to kill it's not that either
because even that fear even that fear
you you you kind of get a control of
that fear because you know you can't
dwell on it because you know if you
dwell on the fear of one of your guys
getting wounded or getting killed then
that's gonna detract from the very thing
that you're supposed to be doing that
will most likely prevent your guys from
being wounded or killed if you're
dwelling on that fear you won't be doing
the things you should be doing like
planning and training and preparing and
inspecting and reviewing and leading so
even that fear wallets persistent and
heavy and potent it's you have some
level of control over
but when something goes wrong when
something happens and you're responsible
and the burden of command settles down
with its monstrous monstrous weight on
top of your shoulders because there's no
one else to blame that's what I'm
talking about and actually I felt it for
the first time really a little bit
during my first deployment that I did to
Iraq and my platoon we we did what we
were supposed to do some things didn't
go right
not nothing crazy but mistakes were made
and when there was actually back to back
to back missions with related targets
that we were going after and I was the
assault force commander and I think one
of them I might have even been the
Ground Force commander so I was clearly
responsible for these missions and there
were some mistakes made and my
commanding officer came and spoke to me
about it you know pulled me aside to
point out the mistakes and the resulting
impacts that these mistakes were gonna
have and he wasn't happy I mean he
wasn't he wasn't mad because we had a
good relationship and he was talking to
me just straight but he wasn't happy and
you know I kept a calm face and I took
ownership and said hey my fault this is
the things we're gonna do to fix it you
know but even though I kind of kept a
calm face in front of him when he left I
again I felt like this retching in my
stomach that that I had made some kind
of mistake and and one of the worst
things about is there's nothing you can
do like the mistake happened you can't
go back you can't fix it and I can't
compare that feeling to anything else
really that I've felt because I've never
felt anything else that feels like that
enough I've talked about it with my
friends and leadership positions
overseas and like actually the first
time is actually stoner that talked to
me about this this gut feeling and he
had something going on and yeah he's
like he's like you know that feeling and
I was like oh yeah I know that feeling
and like I said I've never I've never
felt this feeling this gnawing feeling
in your gut that's eating you from the
inside I I think you see it sometimes if
you watch you know some movies try and
capture this feeling of where it's
basically where someone's life is
falling apart but they're trying to keep
a facade up that everything's going okay
have you ever seen the movie Fargo no
okay I got you on this woke up in this
movie Fargo there's a guy and he's he's
a car salesman and he's been fudging the
numbers and then he's he's he's trying
to kill someone there's all these things
are happening and it's off and he's a
very I would say a very naive person mmm
and he's you know married and he's got
kids and he's trying to do this stuff
that's not right and he knows it and
it's starting to come apart and that
that's the kind of thing we you can see
it's just eating him from the inside so
I think it's that that type of knowing
deep feeling where everything is going
wrong and there's nothing you can do
about it that's the that's the closest I
I think I can come is it's just when
things are going so wrong there's
nothing you can do about it and I think
that that feeling that feeling for me I
think that's why number one that's why I
always say combat is humbling it's
because of that feeling right there
where you something went wrong you
couldn't stop it you couldn't control it
you can't fix it it is what it is
and that makes it humbling extremely
humbling and because of that it made me
want to make sure that I did everything
humanly possible to prevent
from that to prevent that feeling from
crabbing hold of me again if if I could
help it it opened up my mind it made me
it made me always want to listen to
other people's input because I always
said to myself wait if I couldn't see
what was going on over here how do I
ever know where my blind spots are hmm I
always think I must have blind spots
somewhere there must be something I
don't know see something I don't
understand
how can I listen I need to make sure I
listen to other people's viewpoints and
perspectives so that I don't so I can
cover and and yeah cover as many blind
spots as possible hmm review other
methods and other ideas and other
principles to see what I could learn
from them and when people raise opposing
points to me I don't object to them it I
don't bristle up and it's it doesn't
offend me when somebody says something
that that isn't that I don't agree with
it doesn't offend me at all in fact I
want to know more about it and as I as I
go through my life I try and continue to
listen I try to absorb opposing opinions
and process them and I want to just
understand them I want to understand the
context of them I want to understand the
perspective of them it's it's how I
think I'm going to eliminate as many
blind spots as possible so when someone
would tell me like a new tactic right a
new tactic when I was in the teams and
someone said hey we're doing this now
and there's of course when somebody
tells you something new there's always a
part of you that says that whistles up
to it and I again those humbling
situations that feeling in my gut that I
didn't want to feel it pushed that that
ego down because I actually want to hear
what your idea is I want to hear if this
is a blind spot I haven't noticed I want
I want that idea to work I want to see
how it works I want to see if it works
and sometimes they would work
and it's any and I would learn something
sometimes they wouldn't you know
sometimes it would reconfirm the reason
and then that person would learn hey the
reason we don't do what you're wanting
to do is because of this and so now I'm
helping them with a blind spot that they
might have
but either way my goal was always to
learn to hear other people's viewpoints
and that's the way I remain today those
other viewpoints are gonna make me
sharper I'm gonna read things so that I
can see them from other angles
understand things from other angles they
can strike when you understand something
from another angle you can strengthen
your position or you can leave your
position if you realize that your
position is wrong and it's gonna make me
better and it's making me better not for
me not cuz I want to be better but for
the people that around me the people up
and down the chain of command that I'm
trying to support them so I can do my
job better as a leader as a follower and
as a person and also so that I can as
much as humanly possible avoid that
wretched thieving miserable feeling in
my guts so I was thinking a lot about
that and tonight we're gonna explore
some principles of war actually called
general rules by this individual
Machiavelli this is a good Machiavelli
Nicolo Machiavelli this is the guy that
wrote the prince he's got all kinds of
great quotes out there it's better to be
feared than loved if you can if you
cannot be both he's God never never was
anything great achieved without danger
here's one if an injury has been done if
an injury has to be done to a man it
should be so severe that is
vengeance need not be feared that's
pretty ruthless here's another one
hence it comes about that all armed
profits have been victorious and all
unarmed profits have been destroyed you
know one more quick quote as you you can
you can just google Machiavellian quotes
and you'll find a bunch of great ones
men rise from one ambition to another
first they seek to secure themselves
against attack then they attack others
and that's actually from the prince
which is his most famous book and if you
think about the process of being a human
being
that right there is very accurate and
you can really see that with accuracy if
you overlay that on jujitsu first you
seek to secure yourself from attack and
then you attack others right when you're
rolling at first when you first start
you're just trying to defend you're not
to get choked and then eventually you
can stop from getting choked and you can
stop from getting armlock and you start
trying to attack those people in or walk
them so that's Machiavelli and if you
don't know anything about him he was an
Italian really a politician and a
diplomat and but on top of that this was
during the Renaissance period and and
he's an actual Renaissance man so he was
a poet he was a philosopher he was a
playwright he was an author of books
born in 1469 died in 1527 from 1503 to
1506 he was in charge of the Florentine
militia and when he was in charge of
that militia he didn't like mercenaries
because he realized the weakness of
mercenaries is that they they're they're
getting paid that's why they're fighting
or not fighting become their true belief
system so he raised and recruited a
citizen army and they were well
respected on the battlefield and they
fought in some pretty good battles and
won but it didn't last forever
Florentine was eventually defeated and
dissolved and Machiavelli was accused of
conspiracy and tortured
and I of course whenever I I go down a
lot of rabbit holes but I went down that
torture rabbit hole for a little while
yesterday and they pretty brutal about
it but he they thought to use a
conspiratorial
out of him they eventually just exiled
them and that's when he wrote his book
the prince which I'm sure will cover on
here at some point this is where you
hear this is where the word
Machiavellian yeah you know that's kind
of it usually refers to his book The
Prince and and usually that word
nowadays is used to describe someone
that's kind of scheming and unscrupulous
if like if you look it up in the
dictionary that's it'll give you a
definition along those lines and like
someone that's trying to snake and
making things happy it happened but in
like I said I'm sure we'll cover that
book at some point but after that he
wrote a another book which is called the
art of war and it's it's definitely a
really good book it's you know we will
probably parse through the entire thing
at some point but one thing that's good
about it is in the end of the book he
part seven of the book and there's yeah
that's the last the last part of the
book he basically breaks out the most
important principles from the book which
makes it pretty easy and straightforward
to the talking to or to explain them and
and then you can get the details on like
I said I'm sure we'll get granular at
some point on it but here's what he says
in this book he's and it's bear with me
a little bit only because the the
translation is old I know that I have
told you many things which by yourself
you might have understood and considered
notwithstanding I have done it as today
also I have told you for to be able to
show you better meaning there of the
quality of this army and also to satisfy
those if there be any whom have not had
the same commodity to understand them as
you
normy thinks that there are other to
tell you than certain general rules the
which you shall have most familiar which
be these which is his way of saying
listen I wrote a lot of stuff
I'm glad you understood it or at least
you say you did but just in case some
other people can't understand it I'm
gonna break it down for you very simply
in these general rules and and like I
said the translation the translation
that that I read of this book is called
the tutor translations by and it's
translated by a guy named Peter
Whitehorn in 1560 so we're talking like
somewhat archaic language and it's a
little bit tricky you know to get
through brought up I'll talk through him
and we'll get into an understandable
format and there we go so like I said he
says hey look I wrote a lot of stuff
here's the general rules that you should
be most familiar with here we go number
one the same that help if the enemy hurt
if thee and the same that help if the
hurt if the enemy that one's pretty
straightforward right what benefits the
enemy harms you and what benefits you
harms the enemy straightforward I think
you know that's one of those common
principles that across the ages everyone
says and the reason they say that it's
because people forget it people forget
that if if if we're if we can hurt the
enemy in any way it's helping us and
anything we do that benefits us is gonna
hurt the enemy yeah
so sometimes we forget that mm-hmm
that's why many of these various canons
of principles on war remind us of that
because it's an important fact number
two he that shall be in war most
vigilant to observe the devices of the
enemy and shall take most pain to
exercise his army shall endure least
perils and may hope most of the
so what does that mean that means pay
attention that means be vigilant in
observing the methods and plans of the
enemy when you're in war number one pay
attention to who you're fighting against
hmm understand who they are
Andy Berke mm-hmm he was going to do an
e bi I think it was an e bi match yeah
you know he was going against yeah Craig
Jones
yeah you know anything about Craig Jones
yeah Craig Jones is Savage
Andy you know he's he's awesome but
wouldn't wear up or training we're
training hard
mm-hm he goes and competes against him
and loses fast yeah why do you lose he
lost because gweld number one cuz Craig
Jones is awesome and you know what
Andy's real good at he was good at all
of jiu-jitsu but he's got real good foot
locks got real good heel hooks he likes
to play that game you know it's training
with me training with Dean list do you
and so he's rolling in didn't know much
about Craig Jones in fact he didn't know
anything about Craig Jones oh dang he
just said oh yeah he's good whatever
yeah
not not in a disrespectful way right but
you ever heard somebody say like when
they say hey woody woody or what do you
think about your opponent's left hook or
whatever they say what do you think
about your opponent's ground-and-pound
and they say I'm not worried about my
opponent mmm it's what I'm gonna do it's
not what they're gonna do you don't mean
and I don't mean that in a bad way I'm
not trying to say Andy was cocky but a
nice thing was like look god you know I
did you did sir yeah though this
approach yeah like I do just do it hey
and also there's a little bit of like
hey well you might go against this guy
but he might get hurt or you might have
this or whatever you know what I mean so
right and it was a tournament as well so
you can't really get focused on one guy
you're gonna be fighting three or four
guys and one night you just got to get
your jujitsu game up yeah so Andy rolls
in and he went right into Craig Jones's
game in seconds and and the other thing
was and he's super relaxed like I mean
he's he's relaxed anyways so he's like
okay this is do you know we're just
gonna do some jiu-jitsu
and and it'll escalate over time and
eventually you know something you know
will get to that point and whatever and
he goes in and boom and goes right into
like wanna crack Jane Craig Jones is
like really good moves it just goes
right into it for him and you know I was
bummed
and obviously Andy's bummed but didn't
do any you know we me I should have been
like hey man let's look at your
opponents let's check out their game cuz
if you just know you know how it is if
you're aware of someone's game you can
definitely mitigate it you can't defeat
I'm not saying he could defeat Craig
Jones but he would have been he wouldn't
have fallen into that in a matter of
seconds he would have been oh this is
his move there I need I know what to do
to at least mitigate the first attack
the second attack right if you don't do
that you're gonna you can have problems
and any and he got and he came back and
read that he's like you say yeah that
guy's good so props to my boy Craig
Jones you beat my my boy hopefully you
guys will meet again one day and you'll
get it he'll get another go and he'll
know your game a little bit better but
bottom line is study your opponents
study your opponents now can you go to
farm of that yeah you can because some
people think oh I wish that happens
sometimes when the UFC some little miss
Wade or they'll get hurt and they'll
throw a new opponent Matt wasn't ready
for that guy had been training for a
strike or now you're putting me up
against a grappler or whatever yeah so
you know Sarge this is pretty cool Sarge
who was a really good was and he is a
really good wrestler he's also jiu-jitsu
now but he was he said when he would
train for wrestling you know cuz he was
a high school wrestler at Poway which if
you know anything about wrestling in
California or actually in America you
know Poway high school has a like real
dominant wrestling program and he was a
wrestler there as was his brother but he
said when he would train he would he
would picture someone with no face
and it's because you know when you're in
the high school wrestling scene out here
in California you know the people that
you're gonna come up against right in
the tournament you're gonna come up
against these six guys you know that two
of them are good or whatever but he just
say no anyone he would look at him he's
like when I would look at him before a
match I wouldn't even I just see like a
blur just fog in their face and then he
said once he would knew he was gonna go
against that guy
then he'd look at him in a calculate
their face and be like I'm gonna kill
this guy okay but that's why his point
in that was he didn't want to get like
his mind off set by oh it's not who I
expected it to be right so he wouldn't
have any expectation on who's gonna be
he was just gonna get in the murder mode
and then when he when he finally
realized that they're walking out with a
map but then then he'd look at their
face think okay this is the guy I'm
going against and I'm gonna kill him mmm
which for Sarge you know that me he's
the action so observe the methods and
plans of your enemy absolutely next part
of his you you have to endure much
hardship and training of course you
gotta train hard so observe your enemy
know what they're doing and then train
really really hard and you're gonna have
a greater chance for victory of course
common sense next one number three never
conduct by men to fight the field if
first thou has not confirmed their minds
and knowest them to be without fear and
to be in good order for though for thou
oughtest never to enterprise any
dangerous thing with thy soldiers but
when thou seest that they hope to
overcome so again we're dealing with
some Middle English er I think you
English linguists people can get at me
if I'm wrong but we're pretty close to
Middle English maybe it's a little late
Middle English but we're in the ballpark
so what is he talking about they're
never lead your soldiers into an
engagement unless
you are assured of their courage and
then he actually says unless you know
them to be without fear which is the
stretch in my mind because you're gonna
have people they're gonna be afraid in
fact when you can you're gone it people
are gonna be afraid when they're going
into combat ninety something percent a
high percentage of people are gonna have
some level of fear but you do need to
make sure that they're gonna be able to
overcome that fear so if you've got
people that are shaking in their shoes
and they feel you know you think they're
gonna do not they've not been tested at
all well then that that could be a real
problem there's an in the question
becomes okay well how do you test if
someone's gonna be afraid or not what do
you think they do in the military with
people what do they do what to make them
not scared read tests they're here yeah
how do you test for fear put them in
scary situations for scary situations in
training make them rappel off the high
tower make them extend to Airborne
School
hey Airborne School I would say you know
of course there's there's some level of
some things that you need to learn in
Airborne School but you're basically I
mean you can literally throw a sack of
potatoes out of an airplane with a
parachute on and it's gonna land up
pretty much okay most of the time and
that's what you do when you go to the
school you learn the proper exit
procedures when I went to airport school
tech hazy here's the actual procedures
here's how you land you're floating down
you don't have much control over your
parachute so there's not a lot to learn
technically it's not like a major skill
set I mean it's a thrilling pretty this
way it's a three week school right it's
not like it's on it's not a long
intensive school about learning how to
pack parachutes or even how to maneuver
yourself here cuz there's only so much
you can do hmm so what is it that's
important about Airborne School what's
important about Airborne School is
you're gonna overcome the fear of
jumping out of a damn airplane mm-hmm
that's important that's why an airborne
you go talk to the 82nd Airborne
Division of 101st Airborne Division
those guys are awesome and they have
that little thing that they've all done
that has put them they've been screened
out a little bit because some people are
gonna be afraid so yes that's what you
do you make people do hard
everything's I mean in the SEAL Teams
it's the same thing what do they do
you're gonna learn how to parachute then
you're gonna parachute at night then
inter parachute at night into the water
mmm
then you're gonna jump out of a
helicopter at night at you know 20 feet
into the darkness and with a boat and
you're gonna rig that thing up and
you're gonna dive at night and you're
gonna swim at night in the open ocean oh
you're just gonna go so that scares some
people if somebody has never really
scared me yeah I have no fear of sharks
let me rephrase that I have no fear that
a shark is randomly gonna bite me if I
was in the water and there were sharks
I'd be scared yes and I know that
they're sharks in the water since that
guy should be here but I don't know I
feel lucky yeah I feel like sharks don't
really want to eat me in that very much
they'd rather eat like someone like you
well I guess if you're on a surfboard I
guess that increases the chances from
what ended yeah yeah because you look
like a seal sure I got like a sea animal
seal yeah so that's what you do you put
people in situations where they're gonna
be afraid you know and this is something
that I think everyone should do if you
have a job that's gonna cause stress you
want to put people in stressful
situations so that's how you test that
fear and again you're not going to
remove the fear from people what you
want to figure out is can they overcome
the fear yeah that's what you want to
figure out what else you say know that
they're organized
never make an attempt unless you unless
you see they hope for victory hmm so you
gotta convince if you're telling your
guys like hey we're probably gonna lose
yeah you don't say that you say look
it's gonna be hard but there's a chance
we could take this you know what I mean
yeah yeah you got to get them in that
attitude not the attitude of like oh
we're just gonna lose we're just going
down here for no reason
yeah don't let that happen yeah number
four it is better to conquer the enemy
with famine than with iron in the
victory of which fortune may do more
than valiant nests that one's pretty
self-explanatory it's better to defeat
the enemy by hunger than steel you know
it's better to let him starve than have
to go and fight him and then he says in
such a victory
the fortune like your luck counts more
than volumous which is cool
understandable this is one of those
things where heard me say before the
best victories are the victories where
the person doesn't even know that you're
fighting them that's the best victory
and then if you can if you can maintain
your ego after you win and you don't
glow then they never even didn't even
register it Yeah right then another and
a fight they didn't know they were gonna
fight yeah that's what you want this is
very similar but both this is this part
I'll throw a little back at it in such
fortune victory counts more than Val
unis
yeah good fortune is gonna help but
guess what we're gonna make our own luck
we're gonna make our own luck that's
what we're gonna do hmm
we're gonna and we're gonna make bad
luck for the enemy we're gonna dry up
River so we're gonna damn River so they
can't grow food mmm that's what we're
gonna do mmm so when it cut off supply
chains that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna make up we're gonna make fortune
favored us yeah number five no purpose
is better than that which is hidden from
the enemy until you have executed it
boom pretty straightforward no plan is
better than that which you have
concealed from the enemy until the time
you execute it it's no doubt true in
life true in business true in jiu-jitsu
that's what just essentially the element
of surprise surprise yeah if you if you
if your enemy doesn't know what you're
gonna do yeah and then you're done and
they go that was a nice arm walk yeah or
wow you really took over that market
share and I didn't see it coming yeah
yeah if you don't see it coming that's
really it they see it coming from a mile
away it's like huh yeah you can still do
that sometimes Dean does that yeah but
we did we talked about that but he does
different things though like yeah yeah
he'll like many many steps yeah yeah
he'll tie up your defenses while it's
all when you when you see the incoming
mm he ties up all your defenses like as
it gets close
number six - no in the war
how to understand occasion and to take
it help if more than any other thing to
know and war how to understand occasion
and take it helpeth more than any other
thing what does that mean that means you
one of the best skills you can have is
knowing how to recognize a good
opportunity in war or in life and take
advantage of that opportunity that is
more beneficial than anything else and
you know what the biggest and most
blatant example where you see this well
your kids aren't old enough but with
kids mm-hmm just kids kids have so much
opportunity in life yeah and they just
don't take each other like they should
yeah right yeah yeah what I could see
how that could be for sure but I think
that's because they have hard time
connecting now and then the future you
know I guess that's the thing yeah
there's no doubt that they have there's
no doubt that they have that athletes
yeah real good athletes the same thing
they have all this potential yeah any
time someone well not anytime oftentimes
somebody that are some people that are
given a gift yeah this is given to him
hmm
they don't have to work for it and they
don't want to take advantage of it they
don't see the opportunity they don't
take advantage of the opportunity yeah
ever that skill set is yeah good yeah
almost like um you know when you give
the kid a gift versus or money versus if
they earn it yeah I think you covered
that up a little kid yeah that's that's
way covered on where the warrior kids
yeah so when you earn it it's like you
know the hard work sort of it takes and
you can appreciate it and then whatever
comes out of that but yeah if it's given
to you you just you run the risk of
squandering it for sure especially when
the going kind of gets rough you know
yeah no no next nature breed a--the few
strong men the industry and the exercise
maketh many
what does that mean that means you know
nature makes very few strong brave men
but hard work and training makes many
boom you gotta work for it yeah you want
people to be brave you want people to be
have courage make them strong make them
work hard
mm-hmm that will absolutely increase
their bravery
remember that question we got asked a
while ago about how do I make my unit
guy was in a military military you know
how do I make them proud how do I
increase their level of pride train hard
yeah they will get physically stronger
they will get mentally stronger and from
that they will start to take pride in
themselves and try to themselves as a
unit mm-hmm eight discipline may do more
in war than fury figured you'd like town
yeah kind of like that one discipline
counts more than fury in war discipline
counts more than fury in life I'm not
discounting emotions I'm not doing that
because you can't because sometimes men
people's emotions they get they will
carry them through a really tough time
period that's why in discipline because
freedom in the Field Manual I talked
about how you got to use both its logic
and you got to use emotions yeah and
when sometimes when emotionally it
doesn't make any sense or you're gonna
break emotionally you got to go with the
logic of the situation like I got to
drive through this
yeah and vice versa sometimes the logics
like this it makes no sense whatsoever
yeah and it turn to the emotional side
yeah but discipline he says may do more
and he's right it's not 100% like
discipline because if you have people
that are just discipline but they have
no heart they have no emotion well how
good are they
mm-hmm they're not that good mmm they're
not they're not as good as the person
that has both yeah there's not as good
as a person that has discipline and a
little bit of fury you know they can
kind of get crazy when they need to but
in MMA you see this you'll see someone
when they're young and they'll lose some
fights because they'll they'll sit
someone down or whatever and then
they'll just go crazy trying to catch me
look at Conner triangle
mm-hmm you have to maintain your
discipline even during the the actual
battle you have to maintain your
discipline you can't let the fury get
ahold of you yeah too much fury
discipline fear yeah you don't do you
watch the side work fight right the
reason Amanda Nunez yes so this is what
it seemed like he's fast but this is
what it looked like
where cyborg landed like a solid one and
a man in Nunez as a response unleashed
fury like some legit fury fury but it
was discipline fury because when she
started landing hard ones she didn't
like overcome it it was like really
balance you know he looked great but
there was some there was a lot of fury
fury there like it wasn't like all just
spoken calculated like punches to do if
there was fury and but Tim Kennedy
someone's like the UFC tweeted out like
she's throwing haymakers and Tim
Kennedy's like those aren't haymakers
because every single one of them hit
yeah they were full punches I'm Amanda
that were nailing cyborg right in the
head yeah and most of time like in five
times in a row you don't you don't
normally see five punches land
yeah it's especially not punches that
are thrown with that much fury yeah you
can kind of tell one like you see like
their their feet when they're you know
throwing punches like you could there's
like a huge forward lean if they're
haymakers there's like this huge forward
leans and they're usually pressing
forward like fully but when they're like
disciplined there's like that you see
you can see the balance like they'll
back up just a little bit you know it's
good so good yeah
so who's crazy discipline may do more
than fury so you know what make sure you
have some discipline
all right next one number nine when any
depart from the enemy's side for to come
to serve thee when they be faithful they
shall be unto thee all these great gains
for that power of the adversaries are
moored
minused with the loss of them that run
away then tone of than those that be
slain although that the name of a
fugitive be to new friends suspected an
old too odious too old odious so what is
he talking about traitor sir three is
talking about
so nice a win any depart from the enemy
side to come serve you so when people
leave the enemy and they come to serve
with you they're gonna be more loyal and
they're great they're great acquisition
and actually he's saying that people
that leave the enemy and come to your
side are more powerful for you than
people that you've killed and they're
they have more value the when they come
aboard your team they're gonna be
suspected you know the the old that your
team is gonna look at him with like a
cautious eye and the team that they left
are gonna hate them yeah they're gonna
hate them that was weird when
Solzhenitsyn was saying that when they
would capture the Russian turncoat
soldiers that were now fighting for the
Nazis as soon as they spoke any Russian
they'd kill him that was that was a
pretty scary thought so this is very
accurate from that perspective yeah give
you're a traitor we're not even gonna
give you a chance we're just gonna kill
you yeah wait so who wait who so the
Russians the Russians didn't kill him
that no so there was a whole group of
Russian soldiers yeah that turned
against Stalin and turned against Russia
and started fighting for the Nazis yes
and so when the Russians would capture
those what they considered to be
traitors as soon as they heard a soldier
speaking Russian they'd kill him the
Nazis II mean they were they were
Russian soldiers fighting for the Nazis
was it possible that was the guys name
so there was a German or sorry a Russian
general that was the leader of that
whole group the vassal army I think was
the name yeah and so when
the Russian Stalin's Russian actual red
soldiers would capture these traitors
that were fighting against them now yeah
they would if they heard him speaking
Russian they'd kill him hmm so this is
from that perspective it's accurate hmm
yeah I wonder why they're more valuable
you think because what because or what
or loyal he said loyal right - well the
the dirty Russian soldiers that were now
fighting for the Nazis they would fight
to the death because they knew that they
were dead anyways right I captured yeah
like if they got yeah so yeah they were
they would fight even harder the thing
that I'm not sure about this is well I I
guess I agree with it I I do agree with
it
when someone's a traitor you're suspect
of them right yes II know you're just
you're just like here you get your
you're a traitor
I'm suspect to you yes oh it's gonna
take a little time for me to actually
trust that you really came to my side
yeah but I guess like when you think
about just like I said you know they
know they're dead anyway kind of thing
where it's like okay let's I mean you
were enemies whatever and one of my guys
goes to you and says hey I give up I'll
help you I give up
you're like okay he gives up I get it
and let's see what he has to offer kind
of thing but I suspect yeah but you're
suspect but let's say a guy in your team
used to be on my team and I know that
I'm pissed at that guy yeah and then he
gives up now to me to my guys like might
I see him or whatever and he's like I
give up I'll help you oh no no no you
don't give up you're dead yeah so it's
like that like I say they know they're
dead anyway what the Russians did to the
vaasam soldiers yeah so you go you
traded okay cool you're dead and that
makes sense right so that's probably why
they have to be loyal because it's
either loyalty or death you know they
can't give up anymore if I am NOT a
traitor I can give up and get BP owb
whatever I can I can give up I have that
option trader who already made the trade
he doesn't have that option that's why
he's loyal he has to be like at a
minimum he's gonna fight to the death
yeah and it's interesting too that
traders are you know in the business
world because in the business world you
know there's every
always recruiting there's a limited
number of their human capital limits and
in the world and we can only get so many
people that can do this job mm-hm and if
you have skills in that job you're
getting recruited all the time and so
that's that hurts when they leave mmm
and that's why and and just to kind of
close the loop on this when they leave
almost all the time their reason the
reason that they're leaving is because
of leadership mmm or I should say lack
of leadership inside their organization
so if you have a if you have a problem
hanging on to people in your
organization it's most likely a
leadership problem not a comp problem
not a midlife crisis problem for the
employee it's a leadership problem
because good good people will stay with
good leaders and if there's not good
leaders they're looking for another job
they're looking for another way they're
looking for another opportunity mm-hmm
leadership leadership leadership and get
some number 10 better it is in pitching
the field to reserve behind the first
fun aid enough then to make the front
bigger to disperse the soldiers what
that's saying is it's better to keep
your reserves just behind them to keep
some reserves just behind the front
lines rather than spread out your
reserves and take on a bigger front
trying to hold more area it's better day
you know this is prioritized next keep
your keep your focus of effort even with
your reserves keep focus of effort keep
them consolidated so you can utilize
them well next up number 11 he is
difficult Lee overcome which can know
his own power and the same of the enemy
okay let's that was almost like a Yoda
fight
sir he has difficulty overcome so what
we're saying there is it's hard to
overcome someone who knows how to
recognize or knows and understands his
own power and the power of the enemies
or does I mean know your strengths and
weaknesses that's what it means yes
since who says that right yes something
about yes deal definitely number 12 the
valiant nests of the soldiers availeth
more than the multitude sometimes the
situation helpeth more than the valiant
is so what we're talking about there is
that the bravery of the soldiers is
worth more than the number of soldiers
you have makes sense if you have brave
courageous soldiers they can take a lot
more and they can do a lot more than
people or soldiers that are afraid so
you want brave soldiers and then it says
the site what does it say that sometimes
the situation help if more than the
value Ness so even that what Trump's the
courageous and what Trump's the bravery
is what's the what's the terrain
situation you know what's the
environment that you're in what are the
rules of the game what are the rules of
the game that you're playing because if
you if you know the rules you're gonna
be in a much better situation the this
happens in jiu-jitsu right yes because
the rules are always a little bit
different there's no unified set of
rules in jiu-jitsu yeah there's some
close but there's no unified set of
rules and sometimes someone will lose
simply because they don't know the rules
yeah and then once you know the rules
you gotta train to the rules yes like
EBI yes
EBI you have those positions that you
start over in if you're an overtime you
started in spiderweb you start on the
back right if you don't if you don't if
once you know those rules then you got
to practice those positions so you can
finish that one walk so you can finish
from the back or fruit you can escape
from you to one of those two
yeah if you don't know that you don't
practice it cause like for instance I'm
pretty good at finishing on arm lock
pretty good at finishing an armlock sure
on the back I normally transition from
the back to another position hmm so I
would if I was going an epi tournament
I'd have to go and focus on what that
rule set isn't make sure I know how to
win from that position yeah yeah
absolutely yeah big one is the
submission only versus points so if
people like let's say they spend ten
years competing with points in the
tournament's you know then they go to
submission only with a guy who's only
trained in submission only he's gonna uh
you know is gonna have an Advent
in all these different yet different
ways cuz certain rules don't apply some
do yeah and the terrain park man this is
this is it took me a while to understand
this in my Navy career how important
terrain is and now it's so obvious but
when you're maneuvering on the
battlefield if you know how to read
terrain well you have a complete
advantage over the enemy complete
advantage over the enemy you should be
paying attention to that terrain
studying maps looking at it now they
have all these you can you can simulate
the earth right it's a Google Maps like
a high speed where you can get down at
eye level and you can walk the terrain
and really understand what the
visibility to think that's the kind of
that's that's you should you've got to
take advantage of those tools mmm you
gotta understand the terrain you gotta
understand the terrain that you're going
into in the business world you go got to
go into a company understanding what the
situation is there when you get hired
into a new company you want to know the
terrain you want to know who's got the
clout you know you want to know who the
movers and shakers are mm-hmm
you want to know what things are
off-limits and whatever yeah
wanna know who's buying who's like you
know baby baby you know people always
say there's a billion dollar industry
right like that kind of stuff like oh is
it you know how's the what's the need
for your product I'm remembering today
what's shark tank this is what they
always ask what was the was this a
particular product or no no everyone
like pretty much that's one of the
things
like they asked where they say they'll
be like oh yeah this is like a million
how you know a million people own pets
you know and all these pets need this
you know so you see something so they
kind of they got another terrain in that
way yeah that's just there to know how
many people have pets then they don't
know many people gonna buy that shampoo
dude Shark Tank we maybe we should just
do a leadership show about Shark Tale
what you've learned from shark tank next
up number 13 new and sudden thing make
Army's afraid slow and custom things be
little regarded of them therefore make
the army practice and to know with small
fights a new enemy before thou come to
fight the field with him Oh Middle
English coming at you what what is that
what it basically what we're saying here
is number one new and surprising things
frighten armies hmm the new and
surprising things frighten people so on
the opposing to that customary and
expected things they can handle so what
do you do how do you do how do you how
do you properly mitigate that
therefore you practice and you fight
small engagements to get them
experienced hmm
before you go to battle on the big
battlefield with them when the enemy
that's what you do train hard don't dive
right in get them used to the new
technology that's what you do this is
another good one with kids right you'll
throw your kid into this scenario that
they haven't been into before you give
them a little taste of it mmm oh yeah
this is uh this is exposure therapy once
again I get asked on the warrior kid
podcasts I get asked every like every
day I get at least one question from a
kid that's I'm afraid of what do I do
and I yeah I've usually wait two or
three podcasts
before I answer the same question again
because it's kids they gotta get the
repetition they're gonna get the reps in
yes but it's exposure-therapy you're
afraid of something cool do a little bit
of it and then do a little bit more and
that's unknowingly what I did and where
the warrior kid won with him overcoming
his fear of the water I didn't know that
that was a real thing not until Jordan
Peterson's like this is called exposure
to therapy yeah I guess I need to talk
like Kermit the Frog to imitate Jordan
but but he's like yeah that's exposure
to therapy yeah okay next number 13 now
we're on to number 14 he that with
disorder falleth the enemy after that he
is broken will do no other than to
become of a conqueror a loser if you
pursue a routed enemy in a disorganized
manner victory will be lost and you'll
become a loser keep it under control
Allah
Amanda Nunez right she had the victory
and you ever seen that that one real
quick clip and I forget who the fighter
is that did it isn't UFC the guy takes a
body shot and he keels over like he's
about to like go down and the dude comes
running in swing and yeah the dude
that's keeled over like he's hurt just
back yeah he wasn't hurt he was just
faking it yeah I think he was hurt
talked about Scott Yi yeah maybe he was
hurt but he wasn't it hurt as bad as he
right functional apparently doctor dude
out yeah it was the last thing is his
nickname is Drago I know that it's
interesting that that stuff doesn't
happen more often it's like a trick
football place yeah how come more trick
football players don't happen because
they'd lose their trickery element of it
and they'll sometimes there's a lot of
risk involved there's more risk than
like a traditional play a lot of times
yeah yeah and it's like like the rope II
don't remember that with the rope-a-dope
oh yeah yeah you essentially like act
like you're kind of hurt or tired or
whatever and then they punched himself
out then you get them but yeah yeah yeah
you gotta be careful on that King stuff
so when you do have your enemy on the
run don't go after them crazy okay keep
it under control yeah there's a play in
football called the reverse right and I
thought that because you just said it
why don't they run you know I didn't
play football yeah and when you see the
trick plays yeah then you think well
that seemed to work pretty good why
don't they do that stuff more often yeah
yeah okay so here's a common trick play
right be the quarterback does the sweep
right through they got to the running
back there runs on the outside and then
the running back oh he stops before he
reaches the line of scrimmage he stops
and he throws the football not to a
receiver but to the quarterback mm-hmm
who ran a route on the other side of the
field and cuz no one's gonna cover the
quarterback he's not a receiver you know
and that was wide open the past always
wide open so called we called it past
back to the quarterback so good like a
sweet pass back to the crowd okay but I
can see where there's risk in that one
yes because that's a running back you
gotta nail that throw which is really
hard for running back typically but I'd
say the the one that would always work
is in Pop Warner anyway it would always
work is the reverse it's essentially
like you do a sweep everyone's running
this way to block for this running back
everyone except for the one tight in or
why do you see whatever who's coming
this way and the running back hands it
off to him going this way so he's full
speed running this way so everyone has
to change direction to chase him and
usually that set of fields wide open um
it works way better in Pop Warner and
younger teams because they don't know
like these these situations like they
don't know they just see everyone
running there and they just sort of go
you know more than a professional
they're gonna be like wait I shouldn't
just be you know but that was one I was
like why don't we just always run the
reverse because every time this is this
team that we played against they'd
always run it and it always I understand
why if you ran it every time well then
then the regular reverse order the
regular play would become the surprise
but it seems like it seems like you
could keep people guessing a little bit
more those trick plays always see I
always look at how it's pretty creative
and pretty good yeah
yeah I think you see it like um kind of
like I said like when you go up in like
skill like you're going to the rose or
whatever trick plays don't work is good
they have to be really advanced trick
plays that's what you have you ever seen
like the trick play that like where they
like almost walk off the field yeah and
then they like walk over like there's
something wrong with the ball or
something like stand up and they'll be
like no something's wrong and then they
just start running yeah yeah so even
that and then those can backfire too
because they'll be like if all it takes
is one defensive person to know that hey
that ball is in play right now so they
can just sort of walk over and hit it
out of the hand grab it from whatever
they want because no one's blocking them
you know no one's like everything it's
kind of it's just risky sure you get
more people doing that they're gonna be
like oh they're hip to it anyway would
never work after a while
number 15 he that prepare if not
necessary victuals to live upon is
overcome without iron so whoever does
not prepare food and provisions
necessary to live there's going to be
overcome without any weapons at all so
what does that mean take care of your
people take care of make sure you take
care of your logistics logistics wins
Wars and people need to survive so do
that number 16 he that trusteth more in
horseman than in footmen or more in
footmen than in horseman must
accommodate himself with the situation
so in the ancient time she had cavalry
on horses and you had the infantry men
on the feet and he said if you prefer
one over the other then you have to put
yourself in the right situation where
it's advantageous so that's why it's
good to be well-balanced and not really
prefer one over the other but if you do
then put yourself in a situation that's
most advantageous to your style or
preference of fighting hmm but make sure
you learn how to wrestle because if you
don't know how to wrestle someone else
is gonna dictate to you where that
fights gonna go
17 when Val right see if in the day
there be coming any spy into the camp
cause every man to go into his Lodge
okay so what we're saying is this pretty
straightforward basically headcount if
you want to see if there's a spy the
Camp average send everyone to their
place you know get a head count no big
deal 18 change purpose when thou
perceives that the enemy have foreseen
it was I mean if you if you think the
enemy or if you perceive that the enemy
knows what you're doing didn't change
your plan hmm that's that's what that
means pretty straight forward now where
we don't do that or the reason most of
the time we don't do that is because of
our ego we got our plan and we're gonna
stick to it now this is a total this is
why the leadership is hard because
there's a point where your plan you got
your plan and if you stick to your plan
you can it's gonna work right and then
there's a point where you can stick in
your plan you're sticking with the plan
and it's gonna fail because it's not
working so as a leader this is the
hardest things to do as leaders didn't
recognize like you know what the plan
that I came up with it's not gonna be
perfect but it's still gonna work and
where to go with it cuz to try and
change the plan halfway through is
really hard to do even if you rehearse
the contingencies now if you Earth's the
contingencies properly you're probably
be able execute your new plan pretty
easily if you didn't it's gonna be a
problem so this is one of the hardest
things for a leader to do is to pay
enough attention and then weigh the risk
versus reward because if you're coming
up with if you have your plan and you're
executing the plan and all of a sudden
something change it's not quite what you
thought you decide you're gonna try and
do something completely different what
your change is that you make on the fly
are gonna cause as much confusion as
what the enemy is doing and it's gonna
be a real problem
however like this says if the enemy sees
what you're doing and now they're
reacting to it in a proper way and your
plan is no longer effective you have to
be
you have to be able to comprehend that
and discern whether you should change or
not and that's one of the hardest things
for the hardest decisions for a leader
to make as it's happening
well what's worse than that is we have a
long period of time when you start
talking about strategic plans this is
where ego gets more involved yeah
because when I have this plan and this
is what we're going to do and I'm just
gonna stick with it and if it's not
working I'm gonna do it harder yeah so
that's what you want to watch out for
mmm you know there's like some of these
companies being taken down by online
companies right you gotta have changed
your game plan yeah you know you got to
adjust you got to look at them and say
okay what are they doing where are they
going you know blockbuster like that
like I've said this before blockbuster
could have could have completely
dominated Netflix but what did they do
no we're just over here hey people are
gonna keep coming to our stores yeah you
know there's a certain feeling that you
get when you come into a store you get
to look at on browse with the movies
it's like you could pick up popcorn
where you can you're popular at your
house you know people gonna want to come
into these stores yeah no actually
they're not they already have popcorn at
the house Amazon delivered it yesterday
in an hour by the way yeah and then your
turn through and Alan and yet they had
all the relationships with the movie
places and then with one of those movie
companies called fully production
companies was like what's Warner
Brothers what is that yeah production
studio yeah yeah oh they had studio they
got the relationships with the studios
they could've been like hey we're gonna
start selling this stuff online
yeah and they woulda said well that
doesn't make any sense cuz that it's
gonna be all jumbled up when it gets
downloaded yeah but it's gonna get
better
we're just playing the long game yeah
it's weird that's why I said they were
thinking you know it's too hard to
download a movie on the Internet's gonna
be even jumbled up there's gonna be
offering no one even knew what Bob did
Netflix an event buffering no buffering
is just saying in it situation yeah when
it has to catch up was do you remember
Jeff five years ago there was buffering
on all kinds of stuff but now there's
hardly any buffering barely any
buffering I bet my littlest daughter
doesn't even know what buffering is
they're just streaming
I'm sure she knows what it is but she
has never witnessed it yeah well then
again you know you bad service somewhere
yeah get some buffering they weren't
wrong they were wrong Blockbuster mm-hmm
but they just the whole idea of like
people like coming into Blockbuster and
browsing the movies and buying the thing
is that's true like we did like doing
that yeah but it's because we didn't
have a better option yeah like when you
go like even going to the store
sometimes it's kind of cool and fun you
know sometimes but most of the time at
the end of the day I'd rather compress
the button then go to the store
I'd rather press a button - every single
time yeah yeah and there's also that
thing where you you're it's a positive
feedback loop right it's an echo chamber
I like going on you know to those people
in the in the c-suite of blockbuster
like I'm you know my wife loves going
down and picking out movies and the kids
they love doing that you know this was
like yeah you know my kids love that -
so ain't my teenage daughter likes doing
it too with her friends and like there's
no other option yeah your teenage
daughter would be rather being her own
alone in a room clicking on the next
Netflix movie you know popular popcorn
that got delivered earlier yeah so if
you if you are so on a strategy and it's
not working you got to recognize that
you need to change it note to self
everyone in the leadership position pay
attention to that one next up number 20
soldiers when they abide at home are
maintained with fear and punishment
after when they are led to the war with
hope and with reward know what's that
saying is when soldiers are confined to
their quarters they're kept there by
fear and punishment when they led to war
they're led by hope and reward you know
fear for me is just not a good tool for
a leader to use period I'm not saying
you never this is I'm not saying you
should never use it right you there
should be some element a little element
of fear right does the element of fear
sure right let me ask you this do your
kids have any fear of you at all because
you seem real nice yeah they do yeah
there's a there's enough healthy element
yeah I mean I would say yeah healthy but
I don't know I don't really know what
this day
of healthy fear levels are but yeah you
agree that there is a healthy level of
fear I agree with your kids yes your
kids shouldn't just think that that
there's gonna be no repercussions for
anything that they do
yeah your troops should also feel a
healthy level of fear yeah
it's hard to even use that word because
that word is so negative yeah but there
should at least be a level of like you
know what it won't do that ya know
there's a line with Jocko and you don't
want to cross it yeah line with dad
echo he seems real nice and all cruzi I
think I'm a little bit too crazy though
so sometimes you do have to make sure
people understand that if they cross the
line there's gonna be a problem and my
kids definitely understand if they cross
the line there's gonna be a problem yeah
that makes yeah - real pro doesn't
surprise me and it keeps him in check
yeah next up 20 and I'm pretty lenient
I'm pretty cruisy you're actually
surprisingly cruzi and lenient everyone
thinks I'm gonna be the Great Santini
you probably never seen that movie yeah
but you don't want to raise your kids
like that well who's the girl you don't
want to be all militant and impose
discipline on your kids and make them
number one reliant on your discipline mm
instead of their discipline I don't want
to you don't want anyone like that you
don't want your team to be like that
where they're relying on you barking at
them to tell them what to do you don't
want that then they can't function for
themselves yeah you don't want your kids
to be that way either your kids to think
you know what I need to make a good
decision I could slack off or I could do
what I'm supposed to do I'm gonna do it
I'm supposed to do because I know it's
gonna be beneficial in the end as
opposed to I'm gonna do it I'm supposed
to only because I'm afraid that my dad's
gonna yell at me or ground me or take
away my computer or smash one of my
favorite toys yeah yeah you don't you I
mean the assumption I think anyway would
be that you're like more drill sergeant
I'm not even drill sergeant I'm never I
know you're not but I think it's like
when you look at you or maybe with you
just said like one or two
soundbite you're like all he's theirs
recordings many recordings of when I
used to debrief seal platoons okay and
I'm gonna try and get some of those and
what is it
they're just well it's it's definitely I
could see it's not drill sergeant II
yeah but it's definitely direct and can
be pretty harsh yeah the time he's like
that's what I understand people would
probably it'd only be that way if
somebody really did something egregious
because most the time ago okay what do
you think what do you what were you
think about over here debrief me on that
you know what I mean so yeah and it's
all contextual to like you know I guess
it's kind of natural like let's say I
heard that or I didn't really know your
nothing and I heard that and but I'm
okay he's real direct and real strict
and like all this stuff so it's just
natural to be like oh cuz he's that kind
of guy you know rather than kind of the
understand the nuance like okay he's
talking to these people and that's this
time yeah and then versus but then again
then that it opens it up who knows and
how you'd be so you just see your mind
just sort of wants to disattach yeah
what they have witnessed you know to
everything yeah well even drill
instructors are like drill instructors
yeah I mean it's a it's a training
methodology yeah there's the purpose for
the Mac that way see and you know that
because you've been around as Apple type
of leader isn't doesn't function mmm
that type of leader is not good mmm
that type of person isn't gonna function
within a team yeah so you can't you just
can't be that way is there a level of
intensity sure do I bring a level of
intensity sometimes yes absolutely
but that's not the way to go through
life imposing discipline and fear into
your team you'll end up with either one
of two things a broken team that relies
on you for their discipline or a team
that mutinies against you and comes up
and kills you
frags you in the as they did in the Nam
next number 21 good captain's come never
to fight the field except necessity
constrain them and occasion call them so
what that's saying is good you know good
captain's good leaders never enter into
the engagement unless it's completely
necessary that's it that's a great point
and this is one of those things where if
you're in a leadership position you
shouldn't be doing the you shouldn't be
shooting your gun at the enemy you
should be observing your team shooting
the gun and looking to see where the
enemy is maneuvering - yeah this is a
this is about detachment right here
don't get in the mix stay detached
decentralized command will let the team
maneuver hmm let them understand what
the commander's intent is and let them
maneuver towards victory you stay back a
little bit moniker go diving in there
does that apply to cuz you're the one
who kind of said this example to me one
time I forget it goes on here or not but
you're like um it was about you and your
kids tying their shoes you know yeah see
like I don't know you're late for school
or we're running late or whatever and
they're having a hard time tying the
shoes yeah you're like let them tie the
shoes don't jump in and be like I'll do
it you know I did say that and I've said
it a bunch of times that's a real simple
example that's a little bit more towards
the last question or towards the last
discussion that we just got into I mean
if you let your key if you give you tie
your shoes for your kids all the time
they don't learn on time
yeah and furthermore you literally are
taking away their opportunity to learn
some fine motor skills yeah at that
moment this is not the same as that this
is this is on a broader perspective your
team is doing so your team is in a
firefight mm-hmm and you pick up your
gun you go on the front line you start
shooting at the enemy well now who's
leading right I was looking around this
is the same as you know you're in a
business situation and your team is
trying to come up with a plan and
they're arguing amongst themselves and
you jump in there and start arguing - no
you don't have a good perception of you
should be just standing back listening
to the various arguments take place I'm
not talking about arguments where people
are yelling and screaming I'm talking
about a discussion where they're arguing
different possible
forces of action if you dive right into
those and you started becoming involved
at point-blank range you lose all your
perspective so instead you step back you
don't you don't you don't go into the
field yeah you don't dive into the
argument you step back and you watch the
fight unfold and then as the fight
unfolds you see the best options because
you're at altitude and you're not at
point-blank range one foot from the
enemy fire mm-hmm
this is just detached decentralized
command up 22 cause that enemies cause
that the enemies know not how thou right
order the army to fight and in
whatsoever manner that thou ordained
stood make that the first band be
received of the second and the third
Middle English gets something when we
talking about here well cause your
enemies know not so that means you don't
want your enemies to understand how
you're gonna organize your your army to
fight that's what this is you you want
to confuse your enemy you don't want
them to know exactly what you're gonna
do and then the second part make it make
that the first band may be received the
second and third I'm pretty sure I'm not
sure but I'm pretty sure that that's
just talking about mutually supporting
positions so you want to set your team
up so that they can support each other
hmm
so confuse the enemy don't give up the
plan and set your teams up so they can
help each other
once you're T once a team is alone and
unsupportable they're alone hmm
try not to let that happen 23 in the
fight never occupy a battle to any other
thing then too the same for which thou
hast appointed it if thou wilt make no
disorder
it's a good day it's modern English
appreciation well it makes it hard to do
they spell even words that you know they
spell them all different just so you
know you're looking at this I actually
tightened up some of the spelling and
made some of the spelling more modern
because I just couldn't I'd it was
harder to track man yeah it's hard to
track again this this thing was
interpreted from Italian in 1560 by
George George Whitehead was getting
after the translation yeah so it just
it's it's interesting and this is the
same thing you know I said that when we
did Shakespeare don't need to do more
Shakespeare but people think oh I should
just understand Shakespeare you're not
gonna understand straight it's almost a
different language yeah so you need to
actually break it down like we're doing
with these various statements so what
this one is saying is don't use a
company don't use a don't use a unit for
a purpose other than what you've
assigned it unless you want to cause
disorder unless you want to cause chaos
mmm so you've got your team they're
assigned to do this let them do that
now obviously that can be problematic so
we need to mitigate that because there's
times when team is going to have to do
something that you don't want it to do
and so I'll give you a little example
when you're doing an assault on a target
mm-hmm you have two elements the base
element and the maneuver element the
base element is gonna stay in position
they're gonna sneak up on the target and
then the manoeuvre elements gonna sneak
over to the flank and then the base
elements gonna start firing massive
firepower out the target mm-hm and then
the maneuver element after a little bit
will stand up and start to go through
the target they shift fire off the
target and then you clear the target so
when I was a young kid in the grooves
passengers so we would we would you know
like let's
yeah so we're gonna hit this target
we're gonna do a fire and maneuver on
this target mmm base and maneuver so
what we would do is say okay let's take
all of our heavy machine guns and put
them in the base element and then the
guys with the little pea shooters the
little little m16 pea shooters all those
guys will be on the assault because
they're light and they'll be able to
maneuver really quickly through the get
to the target and then go through the
target it makes perfect sense and I
remember the first time I presented this
type of plan to one of the old guys from
Nam music no don't do that mmm why not
Master Chief this way we have more
firepower in our base and our maneuver
guys can maneuver more quickly here's
the problem when that maneuver element
is going towards the target what happens
if they get compromised and contacted
and now they're that they're the ones
that have to lay down their base they
can't get up and move because they're
being shot at so guess who has to move
the base element has to move and they
can't move very well if they're only
getting cover fire from little pea
shooters so you keep your integrity of
your squads and you utilize them that
way it's like so what you want to do in
this situation is you want to make sure
that your elements can are capable of
doing each other's jobs maybe not to the
fullest extent but they at least need to
be somewhat capable so maybe you put one
machine gun and the expected one extra
machine gun an expected base element and
now you only have a couple machine guns
in the maneuver element but you got them
if you need them so I don't 100% agree
with that that being said you definitely
want to let people do the job that they
were assigned to do mmm
makes sense right you trained them
you've assigned it let's let's try and
keep the plan as it's supposed to be
yeah to the best of our ability but
we're thinking we're not black and white
here yeah leadership is not easy you
know another thing is when you establish
your team's you try and use those teams
for everything if you can and again this
is a dichotomy because as much as you
want to keep your teams together
you also have to train them to be split
up and broken up and combined and miss
mast all together and I would always do
this with all my fire teams so the fire
teams would stick together as much as
humanly possible but guess what I would
also train them the favor of scrambled
up someone would step up take lead and
that'd be a new fire team and we'd start
making stuff happened mmm next up 24 the
so Dean accidents with difficulty are
remedied those that are thought upon
with faculty I had to look up so Dean
because I couldn't even get a clue on
what that one was but it's some sort of
leader or a ruler it's actually a ruler
and this is this is a this is so he's
saying the so Dean accents the
leadership accidents with difficulty are
remedied are hard to fix
when leadership screws up it's hard to
fix those that are fought a pound or are
with difficulty are remedied if you use
your head quickly so yeah there's gonna
be leadership problems and they're hard
to fix unless you think and think
quickly how do you how can you improve
your speed of thinking you know you can
do that
practice this let's say get experience -
right because experience gives you the
practice yeah it's experience if I've
seen something before it's I'm gonna
know you've got a thousand times faster
how I'm gonna react to it yeah if I
haven't seen it before
Ida takes me a while just to comprehend
what's in front of my face so that's why
when we train we train to throw things
okay so first of all when we train we
want to throw things at people that
different scenarios different things
happening where they start to get
pattern recognition oh I've seen this
type of thing before on top of that you
also want to train people
what to do or how to react when they've
never seen it before they've never seen
anything like this before because if I
show you let's say I'm training you for
well I guess we might as well just use a
jiu-jitsu tournament right you did - I'm
training you for jiu-jitsu such
situations right and I teach you how to
defend this and I teach you how to
defend that and I did you have defend
this and I teach you how to defend that
right I teach you how to defend ten
different things and you get pretty good
at it
mm-hmm I also have to teach you a broad
concept of what to do when there's
something that you don't recognize so
hey if the guy grabs your arm I want you
to pull your arm here hey if the guy
starts to go for your neck I want you to
swing your arm your hand underneath and
tuck your chin if the guy starts pulling
towards your back I want you to shift
your leg up and so he can't maneuver
around there so I'm gonna give you exact
steps to execute if you see these things
mm-hmm and then I'm gonna say this if
he's doing something you don't recognize
here's what I want you to do I want you
to tuck your elbows and I want you to
posture and I want you to control his
hips oh okay and then you'll start to be
able to recognize what's going on at
least you're gonna survive yeah I want
you to detach and step back and say
what's he attacking same thing with
combat I'm gonna train you like hey if
he does this you do that if he does that
you do this if you have no idea what's
happening here's what I want you to do
get into a 360-degree perimeter listen
right I mean whatever that that
situation is gonna call for if you don't
know what's happening like if I don't
know what I'm getting flanked from or if
I don't know where I'm getting shot at
for him hey everyone take a knee get
cover don't just start shooting because
that's gonna cause confusion it's also
gonna give away our position
yeah so what we're gonna do when it go
into a 360-degree perimeter we're gonna
hold what we got we're gonna listen
that's our that's our that's our if we
don't recognize what's happening that's
what we're new so we have standard
operating procedures for things that we
recognize and we actually also have
something to do if we don't recognize we
have a procedure for non recognition
yeah yes which is important it's kind of
like I mean it's different I guess but
it kind of maybe
it's in with you know how people
obviously expect the unexpected kind of
thing so it kind of fits in this where
you're essentially trained for
unexpected like we said I would say go
one yes that's the important part it's
not just expect the unexpected
it's have a protocol for when something
unexpected happens yeah here's what
we're going to do yeah because a lot of
times when something unexpected I'm
thinking justa two right now it's
because that's on purpose you know like
these guys with these weird games yeah
tall flexible guys or something like
that they have these weird games and
they'll do stuff that they know or they
kind of rely upon you not have seen it
before let you didn't see before so they
can capitalize when you start to panic
you know or when you can you know if
let's say your arm is out here like um
like there's some leg locks that that
require you to kind of try to spin out
of it then they'll catch you with
something else right it's kind of that
so if you have a protocol that's just
like I don't know whatever the protocol
is safety protocol you know it not only
keeps you safe just and statistically
speaking you know chances are it'll keep
you safe but it'll jam up their game
yeah overall you know especially these
people that they think they capitalize
on you panic you did not know you have
to do you know and you want to have some
kind of a reset position and I used to
use this from fighters like hey here's
your reset position like just get to
here you're comfortable there get them
under control control their hips
whatever yeah combat same thing oh
you're you're you everyone's confused
everyone's mixed up guys are all over
the place let's get to a reset position
in a building yeah yeah now everyone
knows where we are we get a control of
ourselves yeah business same thing we
got we got scenario that we don't know
what's happening you know what General
Quarters like hey we're all gonna go to
our normal positions we're gonna stand
by because we don't know what's
happening right so you got to have not
just to expect the unexpected you've got
to have a protocol to follow when
something is occurring that you don't
understand yet mm-hm some kind of a
reset position mmm put that in your
world
next up number 25 men I earn money and
bread be the strength of the war but of
these four the first to be most
necessary because men an iron find money
and bread but money and bread find not
men and iron yeah that one's pretty
pretty cool pretty self-explanatory now
let me let's go to a business
perspective here a business perspective
here because this is a this can help
people make decisions in the business
world when you're going to make expend
expenditures when you are going to
invest in something in your company it
is important to assess whether or not
you are investing in something that is
going to help you build is gonna help
you grow or if you're investing in
something that is not mm-hmm so for
instance let's say let's say hey our our
we could either take you know fifty
thousand dollars and remodel our current
office or we can take fifty thousand
dollars and we can rent this new sub
office in a more area that we don't have
any presence in so which one is a better
investment like we don't really need
that remodel of our office this other
thing is gonna help us actually grow so
make sure that the investments that
you're making the first thing you want
to invest in is men and iron right you
don't want to invest in money and bread
money and breads gonna be gone yeah and
it doesn't reproduce it doesn't
reproduce itself whereas men and steel
is gonna get you more of that bread and
iron in the long run
mm-hmm or sorry bread and money all
right number 26 the unarmed rich man is
a booty to the poor soldier
what does that mean it means that the
unarmed rich man is the prize of a poor
soldier that sort of means it means it
means be armed and this is the last one
number 27 a custom thy soldiers to
despise delicate living and luxurious
apparel I like that one
what does that mean get your people get
your soldiers to despise delicate living
despise comfort despise luxurious
clothing that's what I'm talking about
they'll be better soldiers they'll be
better people and you feel like I'm
talking to you like what the connoisseur
of comfort comfort you know is in my
firing line right now yeah I dig it
obviously I can't disagree with that cuz
dang I mean yeah when you've been
uncomfortable for an extended period of
time does it not make you a better
person or a little bit yeah it does
there we go yeah you know the whole idea
be comfortable we've to me the story of
you because I know it doesn't rain a lot
here but you used your kettlebells in
the rain and the other day you told me
that story two times you know two days
in a row now
sure right yes yeah today you told me
that even Jade your brother came out was
impressed by your determination so what
is it what is it about that that made
you feel compelled to tell me about it
and B you know for lack of a better word
pretty damn proud that you went out in
the rain and did a kettlebell workout in
the cold yes
well yeah it's strong it and how did you
feel inside I felt strong when it was
over feel better yeah this is it well
yeah I'm asking you real questions right
now everybody seem like I'm joking but
it's actually real you know why because
this is a little step for you and
there's other people that are listening
that would benefit from hearing and how
taking this little step away from
comfort really truly made you mentally
and physically better go
Oh Charles well yeah can I start on that
okay so okay yes I go outside I had a
workout planned it's raining raining
kind of hard to by the way and it's kind
of cold the kind you gotta wear like a
lot of clothes you know so yes I go and
do the whole workout hard too and yes my
brother was like dang that's some
dedication whatever but yes so the
feeling is yeah that I'm actually strong
now you know it's like basically when
you break it down it's like now you're
strong I mean you're not weak so weak
would be like just the littlest thing
will throw you off your plan you know
the littlest thing because you can't
because you're so used to comfort where
you're so used to like the clothing
thing I mean yeah that's kind of weird
too like if if you always got to be
wearing like nice clothes otherwise like
you're kind of you don't go out or so I
don't know but it's kind of say seems
like this ain't the same concept but
yeah if you can endure that stuff and
then how do you feel when you're done
better yeah did you feel better after a
workout in the cold rain where you went
and gone after then you would have had
it been just normal 70 degrees in sunny
SoCal yeah a little bit but I feel like
it's it was just more of a psychological
thing which does help big time because
now you know that rain you just proved
to yourself that rain cold whatever is
not an excuse for years raining cold
doesn't excuse no more no no more
well here's the thing going to battle
you know it's funny here's a good here's
a good expression you saying the Dames
balcony good mm-hmm
when it was raining and cold you know
we'd say good operating weather but it
was like it was kinda it's true is
definitely true because when it's
raining and when it's cold guess what
the people that are you know on watch
your enemy guess what they're doing
they're there Heidi they're all bundled
up and warm so that makes it easier for
you plus there's noise from the rain
which camouflages the noise that you're
making walking through the Jay or the
woods or whatever but that's always a
good one whenever it's
it's crappy weather I was I was say to
myself good operating weather yeah kind
of smile but we used to say to each
others that's like you can't complain
about it you just look at your buddy
it's like when you win the door of the
of the Hilo truck you know the Hilo
truck is know but back in the day we
didn't have a lot of money for budget
and so we'd pretend that we were in
helicopters and we'd be in the back of
big trucks and they just drive out in
the middle of the desert open up the
Hilo truck and open it up open up the
door we jump out like we just got out of
a helicopter right little did we know
that when the war actually came we would
be using vehicles we did we used
vehicles all the time we brick I rarely
rarely used helicopters in Iraq in
Afghanistan they used helicopters a lot
more hmm but for me and Iraq foot patrol
and helo trucks but we didn't have to
call him helo trucks anymore now he just
called me trucks sure but when you're in
a helo truck mm-hmm in 1994 and you get
driven up into the wherever and the door
of the helo truck opens out opens up and
it's raining and it's cold and as you're
getting out of the truck your last
moment to communicate out loud to
everyone you hear someone go good
operating mother and you're like yeah it
is this is gonna suck
yeah yeah and it makes sense so like yet
you're used to being uncomfortable right
or if you like despised comfort and
however you put it yeah not me very
Machiavelli said despised comfort
despising comfort essentially you're
getting comfortable with being
uncomfortable you know how they say that
they do the view so yeah that's what
they're doing so that's why yeah yeah
just basically attended a improves your
chance of success you know may
roadblocks of discomfort come about in
the future that's what I'm indeed and I
I think that not only will the rejection
of comfort make better soldiers it'll
make better people so yes as you said
get out of your comfort zone impose
discipline and disk um
on yourself and you will become a better
person okay and that wraps up
Machiavelli for now but echo speaking of
getting out of our comfort zone and this
is gonna be a little dichotomy here but
getting out of our comfort zone to
become better what recommendations do
you have for us to make that happen
like I said there's gonna be dichotomy
here okay because what do we have well
well there's a lot of things you have
but but yes so at being the connoisseur
of comfort and so you're kind of the
connoisseur of discomfort really in a
way I don't know about that here's the
thing though
people I don't think about it much
though yeah you know what I mean I'd
have to be like actively thinking about
it about what discomfort just about
anything
oh I'm just over here doing what I'm
doing yeah I don't I mean it's with
discomfort just don't care I don't care
there's that old Viking saying it's like
the rain is cold and the old Viking says
how can the rain be cold right the rains
not cold yeah but I don't know I don't
get it how can the rain be cold if it's
cold then it's cold
no it's called to you and it hits you
the rain itself is again that's it's a
play on words yeah yeah that's another
good thing to think yourself another
good thing do you think yourself you
only get wet once yeah I've talked about
that before yeah you're you you're
waiting to go across the river you're
looking for the best body
oh no no just get wet you're gonna get
wet one time what's your wet your wet
doesn't matter yeah it's true so they
suck it up the comfort thing is it's all
it's like context as a huge has a lot to
do with it remember how I told you that
time where it's like you know sometimes
you can just fall asleep on the floor I
know we're in the beach I don't know but
then sometimes you get in you're on your
couch or on your wherever and you just
can't fall see can't get comfortable in
love you know interesting because you
you expect the
effort is what I'm saying but if you
don't have any comfortable expectations
it's like you just be you're just
comfortable it's almost like you're just
appreciative for any kind of comfort but
if you expect mass comfort it's like you
can't get enough comfort you know
because you just expect more it's weird
so like like um okay so you you know you
have experience with cold water right
getting in to hit the surf whatever so
when you're there how hard is that just
not not right like we're just doing it
yeah this is what we're doing this is
weird whatever it's cold
it sucks whatever even if it's but
here's the yeah this is me keep in mind
but still I think he's holds true so I'm
getting in the shower the other it's
cold here let the peace well Pete's
gonna understand because this probably
had my name too so listen you know how
you're cold you know you like it's just
sort of cold so I'm about to take a
shower and you know that kind when you
turn on the shower it's not just doesn't
come out all warming that it takes a few
seconds or whatever so so I turn it on
and hits me Oh cuz you take warm showers
anyone understood anyway the cold water
like kind of hit me you know oh there's
no way I could bear going underneath
that shower like before it gets one no
way no way but then and then whatever it
heats up but I'm thinking like nah like
yahoo guys go in that cold surf like for
a long time and so then I'm thinking no
it's totally in context you know like if
I let's say a minute before I walked in
the shower I was like cool show right
now doing it literally the same exact
time I could do it the same so it's like
a mindset kind of thing Jack even aside
from the training of course I would say
this and the reason that I can't they're
at me it's just like blank no probably
it's not here maybe it is brow but no I
don't know think about this let me get
out of bed right well then again your
routine is different but yeah let's say
you're just sort of going I have an
actual ice bath
yeah but that's different to brace okay
but that's what I'm saying like what if
you get I don't know out of bed or
you're just cruising at home which you
probably don't do but let's say you were
and it was just cold the kind like hot
I'm pretty cold right now I should put
on a jacket right now oh goody
whatever that's how cold it is right
here right not freezing but just I'm
cold right now uncomfortably cold and
then let's say your son comes with a cup
of ice water and dumps it on you huh
right how'd you sneak up on me so you're
saying okay maybe didn't sneak up on you
maybe he's I don't know let's say you
pour the ice water on you okay yours
telling me that you're like whatever
that wouldn't you'd be Viking like can
be like huh like I don't know it's not
cold well I tell you if he was looking
for a reaction from me I wouldn't give
right which I did I dig it there would
be a grappling match happening real
quick though yeah so yeah and I
understands an attack okay so that aside
I'm talking about the actual cold water
in you yeah yeah yeah but it's so it's
not nothing but no it's something but
it's something but that compare that
experience to if he came up to me Bay
hey Dad I have this cup of cold water
it's kind of cold right now do you think
you can like endure this right and
you're like oh yeah I can endure it do
it and he did it I'm not saying that
would be nothing or somehow I'm saying
that those two experiences are different
okay yeah
seem saying so this is the this is
element of surprise is all we're talking
about one year is a surprise to one
you're not if you're surprised it gonna
throw you off a little bit yeah if
you're not surprised you're braced for
it you're good to go
yeah I mean a surprise that's just one
element of a different context where you
don't necessarily exist surprise and
mental preparation mental preparation is
I think the overarching because surprise
it would fall under the mental
preparation right left gonna tell you
that share experience kind of
enlightened me a little bit anyway okay
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
that's a jiu jitsu saying to by the way
yeah is that where you heard him mainly
or maybe that's where I first heard it
yeah because that's a good thing to have
oh yeah that's the that's the backhanded
compliment that Hicks and Gracie told me
when I rolled with him back in the day
what that you were comfortable he goes
he said you're very you're very
comfortable when you're in a really bad
position and I was all happy yeah he's
good at jujitsu yes so but yeah so
that's what it's saying so that means
dude you did to kind of really that last
stratagem or what do you call it rules
you know yeah yeah yeah is essentially
despise delicate living yeah is Jiu
Jitsu delicate living and then it is not
that delicate but it's not brutal
depends are you roll with him yeah
that's true there's some blood on the
mat last night
way I believe anyway dude you get to yes
if we're not in jujitsu already we might
not agree on the different mindsets for
cold and all that but we do agree do
some jujitsu do some jujitsu and when
you do it you're gonna need a key and
what gear do you get none other than the
keys that are made 100% in America from
top to bottom from origin origin main
dot-com that's where you get them you
get whatever you want on there
anything a rash guard so you can do nogi
as well and then you can get t-shirts
and hoodies which are comfortable which
which are the antithesis of what we're
talking about yes because you have
claimed and now this claim has been
supported on social media sites around
the world that the origin jogger pants
which I don't wear are universally the
most comfortable pants of all time
yes yeah still I mean and I went on
searches like my son got a pair for
Christmas
cuz you know when you're in my family
guess what you're getting for Christmas
product yeah so he got a pair and I
tried them on and he was like you gotta
take a bomb
like us how they look because they just
don't know you don't match they does not
their nurse not me yeah cuz joggers as
functional as they are because they're
super functional as far as jogging and
running uh as functional as they are
their that's a style thing like they're
in style right yeah but they're that
somehow related to skinny jeans are they
not yes related that's the look yeah and
later
so you Bri you can't wear skin that can
stay they used to issue and when I when
I was at SEAL team two SEAL team one we
didn't have it seal team two they issued
us joggers but this is back in the day
they were basically like they were
basically like the same thing because it
was cold in the wintertime and guys
would want to run with those things on
yeah but I didn't wear those either but
everybody else yeah yeah weight and
their outerwear they weren't undoing
wear them like over your running shorts
oh okay yeah cool there you go yeah but
these are these are probably gonna be
way more comfortable no one's from
origin um and they're made in America by
the way I don't know if I mentioned that
but yeah those are good jogger
here's the thing you despise comfort
well I don't think you despise comfort
not as much as I should yeah okay that
makes sense to me I don't despise
comfort just like I don't despise the
rest between sets because comfort is
there for a reason
mm-hm when you're kind of cold I guess
that's why I was gonna say earlier you
enjoy comfort more when you have
discomfort Yeah right
oh you don't want to be the person
that's constantly in a feather pillow
temperature-controlled scenario yes you
want to be in like the tough environment
and then you're like oh this feels good
now yeah when you get out of the one
you've been surfing and it's cold I went
surfing the other day with no wetsuit on
and it's a wintertime here by the way
but one of my two actually of my toes
were numb white how it's so how cold is
that maybe like what 55 yeah something
like that yeah I mean I only went for
like 45 minutes
mm-hmm but yeah I was cold when I got
done yeah and then I went in the jacuzzi
and it felt good yeah so really it not
response that comfort
yes but it felt even better than if it
was just a normal day and I wasn't
didn't have a numb
few toes yeah so really it's more about
the ability to endure discomfort that's
really what it is so the less time you
spend uncomfortable the less used to it
you'll be a little more like you know
the less capable you'll be of enduring
it yeah kinda that's kind of the thing
yeah Jack what they're going for anyway
these guards t-shirts joggers
supplements supplements of course joint
supplements which have shaken out to be
the most important supplements there are
it's true or indeed for a semi to
moderate to highly active person that's
it yeah I know this firsthand definitely
so joint warfare krill oil those are for
your joints and for your whole life like
there's stuff that's in joint warfare
tumeric it has all kind it's not just
like yeah it's good for your joints but
it's good for a law it's good for
everything yeah which is as I was you
know reading more about it no there was
an article that sprang up that's what it
was and I was like wow I didn't know did
all this no wonder I feel so good
anyways Joe and we're her loyal
discipline there's also so discipline
comes in lemon-lime which is tasty
there's also the new tropic thunder drop
it because I couldn't call it we
couldn't call it pina colada
because that just not happening no no
that wasn't just a big negative and it
is mulk of course additional protein
additional protein mm-hmm that tastes
delicious that tastes like a dessert but
for real dessert yeah and if you have
kids or if you just well if you have
kids you get them a warrior kid milk
which is the best possible thing you can
buy a child for food in my opinion yeah
tastes well I guess if you get a steak
seriously I think vegetables are good
too not even like steak when I was a
little kid yeah you like burgers I like
the burgers Buster's huh yeah you're
more refined now luxurious no yeah wow
that was an acquired taste getting into
the steak thing
huh yeah just e+ I had to learn how to
cook it better yeah so yeah warrior kid
milk and all that stuff from origin you
can get it origin main dot-com Dutch
comm also chakra at the store it's
called Jaco store so you got it
chocolate are common this is where you
can get shirts that represent the path
you want to represent discipline equals
freedom this winning Co sweetums shirt
here and this is what I realized this
cycle I I know I know I think maybe a
little bit too much into it but this
happened when you wear a discipline
equals freedom shirt to work out
you like won't skip the workout you'll
be more into the workout I noticed that
yeah because you look at it says
discipline equals free you know it's
like you're representing what it's
actually saying it's not one of these
deals where it's like oh a cool star on
your shirt or something which is cool
there's people that have taken that idea
to the next level and gotten the
discipline equals freedom tattoos see
same exact concept and yeah man I've
seen it in like one dude has the dust
macaws freedom I think it's it's
basically on the inside of his wrist you
know try eating a doughnut with that
hand there's no way that's exactly if
that happened you'd you'd be in serious
violation yeah you couldn't do it you'd
feel it like you'd be doing burpees for
yeah 45 minutes yeah after that yeah you
seen I posted a picture of the guy with
it on yeah yeah no there's one guy
that's in subs arm are you talking about
the one guy there's a guy has almost
wrist yeah recently yeah it was that
roll call yeah that's when I took the
picture oh yeah I saw that it was good
see same exact concept man yeah because
yeah you can't not represent now you
know the shirt on boom you got the
tattoo now you can never not represent
or are you gonna pay the price
yeah to yourself by the way you know so
it's like a thing I dig it man
I dig it respect also you get that
tattoo I think you should only get that
tattoo if you if you're you need to
commit first right yeah you commit first
and then get the tattoo don't think that
just the tattoos gonna push you over the
edge
even though I probably will you know but
maybe that's not the best approach for
tattoo decision-making is that so that's
what you're saying
either way yeah anyway it's called jaw
closed or calm you can get your you know
the shirts and and before you get the
tattoo get the t-shirt gets a hat get a
hat says it first yeah there's a lot of
your stuff here in the game cool then
you can step it up a little bit more
hoodies yes
women's stuff I'm gonna have some new
stuff on there too you keep saying that
I know but you know I'm gonna do
meanwhile there's their patches right
now we had a patches oh I don't know let
me double check let me check with the
guy that's in charge of in Israel oh
wait that's you well rest assured hey if
you see something cool get something if
something sold out or something like
that no I don't know let me know I guess
don't know you know what it won't be or
it'll be on the way either way it's
called Chacko store calm a lot of cool
stuff on there if you want something
you're gonna represent in the wild in
the wild better get something also Jocko
white tee on the story that we saw that
on the store to buy them chocolate um
but you can get this yeah it's good and
get it from Amazon as well where else
guess what I'm drinking right now hot
tea yeah you know why comfortable
because a little bit cold busted yeah it
makes sense you're weak you're no
stranger to discomfort so I think you're
kidding
you know whatever but yeah chocolatey
it's one of those deals where even if
you don't like tea that much
you'll probably this doesn't it tastes
like tea but it doesn't taste like tea
can I say that does that make any sense
you know if you drink it that means that
I caught it a condom Chaka white
there's no dichotomy in the factory
teaching the jiu-jitsu class at the
muster and he used the word dichotomy
and then everyone started laughing yeah
cuz the way he says it is like directly
teased directly mocking me risen to work
dichotomy yeah so yeah so yeah Chuck
white tea outstanding uh stuff makes you
dead laughs 8000 pounds but
we already knew that yeah yeah worldwide
deadlift has increased a lot
yeah also it's in Cannes which is good
for me because the whole brewing tea
sequence uncomfortable is I'm very
uncomfortable for me yes so you know can
seems more cool but whatever whatever
you like also subscribe to this podcast
if you haven't already uh on you know
where we listen to podcast there it is I
know I don't think we even need to say
that anymore
okay I've said that for like a year or
maybe even three years that we don't
need to say to subscribe to the podcast
but we do need to say subscribe to the
warrior kid podcast yes check it out
check it out even if you aren't a kid
check it out I use a different voice in
that podcast Dave Burke was talking
about it yeah like I even like that
different I use this voice right here
it's a little bit more aimed at kids
yeah this is just the way I normally
talk what I do because I'm kind of uncle
Jake in that mean uncle Jake is a little
bit more he's not isn't he well not
dorky but he just doesn't have his
little bit of a dark side god yes yeah
yeah yeah that's a good way of putting
it the dark edge he's just good he's
like Uncle Jake is just good across the
board yeah you never know what I might
have a little I might have a little
issue with something and get kind of
crazy on it yeah uncle Jake's not gonna
let that happen so check out the warrior
kid podcast if you want to get some more
information to your kids about being on
the path and you can hear me talk and
tell stories in this voice from uncle
Jake yeah actually something actually
exactly like how do you sound on it
which is good anyway also yes YouTube as
well so we do have a youtube channel if
you didn't know that it does have the
video version of this podcast and also
little excerpts and enhanced excerpts by
the way I was noticing some of your
recent excerpts you can't make excerpts
that are 12 minutes long that's not an
excerpt
that's just like a video well
technically that's that's not correct
because an excerpt is just a part of you
know timely what you saying with the 12
minutes is
man I know and sometimes they're gonna
be twelve minutes there's no way that
everything in that 12 minutes is
important kind yeah that's true okay but
if you paid out your editing city bill
depends on how you look at it though bro
these things are supposed to be an
excerpt should be like ah you know what
boom not two minutes and 28 seconds
later you like yeah I got this Oh dig it
I agree but not a lot you want people to
pull up a couch and even for some of us
there on the computer start and then
boom there the excerpt comes up you know
about maybe a porn or maybe it's like
you saying something in me disagreeing
and then you say well this is this and
I'm saying well that's true but what
about this and you're like okay or
whatever you know it's like a little
it's like a little conversation that's
not two hours seem sane so you know it's
presentable it's good do okay so there's
there's on the YouTube channel there's
long and short excerpt yes that's a good
there's digestible and there's a little
bit more like you know mealtime
conversational you know because it's
less about like the shortness and
shareability
necessarily it's more about like hey
remember the shareability
Oh like I can you watch yeah there's a
minute yeah they're more likely to watch
the minute video than the 12 minute
video but the 12 minute is like the kind
of like if you just want to hear about
like this specific like topic that
happened at tape toilet they're not all
12 minutes no I like this maybe like 8
minutes though either way psychological
warfare - speaking of little excerpts
those are just short short 1 to 2
minutes of how to overcome some type of
momentary weakness that you might have
if you don't have a discipline equals
freedom tattoo on your wrist that's
gonna keep you in check that this is
another thing you can do prior to
getting that tattoo you can just load up
your psychological warfare on itunes
google play mp3 platforms whatever and
listen to those yes which is Jaco
telling you overcome the weakness
mm that is that's that tattoo on your
wrist discipline equals freedom is like
the ultimate psychological warfare
there's weapons it is a weapon like boom
just go home what if you put discipline
on one wrist and freedom on the other
wrist I actually might do that that's
pretty good that's pretty discipline you
know at origin I've been talking to Pete
we're trying to buy a machine that can
make sweatpants wristbands mm-hmm right
and then once we have that power two
things number one I'm gonna make the
best wristbands cuz I do I wear
wristbands every time I workout yeah and
but then there's no good wrist bands in
the world
there's none of them that meet the
standards that I would like them to me
why do you wear we've spent a sweat
primarily oh so it doesn't go on yeah
because it will run right down my arms
in my hands and I'm just dropping
everything and it sucks yeah ramier so
I'm gonna make wristbands that are super
long very and really like just I told
bein like we can put discipline on one
and freedom on the other one right and
you can buy a little set yeah so nervous
Pete Pete shopping for the Machine right
now good exhausted too yes it can make
socks Pete sent me a picture of a
machine and he goes what do you think
this makes and I looked at it and I
don't know I just kind of like logically
it was sort of like a um you could see
stuff 360 degrees around something else
mm-hmm and I was like I bet you I said
socks and he goes down Oh
because I'm not in a good district you
recognize was impressed with my logic
yeah you're deducing deductive skills
yeah it's good I'm impressed too so we
could have been impressed good on it so
on it the company I'm impressed with
always have been by the way so go to on
it calm slash chuckle this is where you
can get kettlebells all kinds of cool
workout equipment that you can just
slowly add to your arsenal at home
you've got a home gym whatever really
good stuff on there also good info on
there so you know if you want to educate
yourself a little bit more bone that's
the place to go
on it doc on slash Jocko really good
stuff on there really good we got some
books
my key in the Dragons which is fully in
stock it ran a little low we almost
didn't make Christmas but we made it
thank God cool thanks to everyone on the
team that helped us and all the printers
around that that printed us copies and
we got a bunch of copies and everyone
got them by Christmas that I know of
everyone that's reached out on Twitter
that said it's not here yet on December
19th or 13th was like we still don't
have it I ordered October house I think
it's company please come and but as far
as I know everyone got him when they but
they got him in time for Christmas
so now we have a lot so if you want to
get Mikey in the Dragons best children's
book ever ever yep yeah yeah disagree
with me no I well I think just by nature
I'm like oh you made a claim let me like
refute it so I'm off thinking but I'm a
geek because obviously I would be like
hey what about this way the word kid cuz
I thought that what age group for which
ok best young best it was it a toddler
that reads miking the Dragons Todd the
best toddler someone they can walk yeah
yeah well some tall is can understand
best children's book picture book with
for ages 5 and under 7 and 16 under sure
my keen the Dragons there ok just wrote
that down order that way the warrior kid
when the kids get a little bit older
order way the warrior kid in marks
mission book 3 has been written I got
pictures from John Bozak today via text
you saw him right witnessed yes yeah how
do you like him we liked him a lot
I showed I showed Danny Reinhart to my
youngest daughter and I've been I've
been I've been telling her about Danny
Reinhart for a long time because Danny
reinhardt's does everything perfect and
Danny Reinhart does everything good and
Marc's kind of jealous of him and I
should and she was she's been she got
all into the name Danny Ryan yeah and
she's already doesn't like him but the
interesting twist on the story is Danny
rhino it's actually a good kid
and he just happens to be talented and
he happens to work hard and he's
actually nice but marks and jealous
so warrior Kid 3 coming out in the
spring and right now we got warrior Kid
1 and warrior Kid 2 marks mission also
got discipline equals freedom Field
Manual the manual for getting after it
in life super stoked on everyone that's
posting pictures and a I'm actually most
stoked when somebody posts a picture
that they've lost 162 pounds yes in 14
months or whatever yeah completely
changed their lives yeah why discipline
it was freedom so you can get that book
for yourself that's also pre tattoo
maybe before you get the tattoo you just
leave this out on your coffee table yeah
right you just have it there because
it's looking at you that book is looking
at you yeah I got a stack of them in my
room I fuel oh yeah they keep me right
on there so if you want if you want the
audio version it's on iTunes Amazon
music google play other mp3 platforms
obviously extreme ownership the first
book that I wrote with my brother Leif
babban taking the lessons that we
learned on the battlefield and
explaining how they can be applied to
your business and to your life and that
was the followed up that was followed up
by the book that we just had come up out
called the dichotomy of leadership and
this is getting granular in how to apply
those leadership principles into your
world also we have echelon front which
is my leadership consultancy and what we
do is solve problems through leadership
if you have any kind of problem in your
organization it is a leadership problem
it is a leadership problem we will help
get your leadership fixed get them
aligned and get them working and get the
team functioning properly we also have a
Leadership Conference that we do it's
called the muster in 2019 there are
three musters May 23rd and 24th in
Chicago September 19th and 20th in
Denver and
December 4th and 5th in Sydney Australia
check out extreme ownership calm for the
details and to register all of them that
we've done have sold out this is and
what I'm saying they sold out this is
when people call me up and say or like
people that I know you know say hey hey
I know a little late just wanna can you
just um can you just reserve three seats
for me and you know these two other
people that I work with and I'm like
actually no I can't
you cannot come well we'll just stand me
back no there's fire codes ik you can't
come yeah everyone thinks you all just
you know no yeah just it's sold out yeah
so you can't have to come the the the
live podcast we're doing January 9th
sold out immediately it's like sorry
gotta be quick on those it yeah so
there's that that we do have this GF
online this is this is the interactive
training leadership training that we put
together and okay so there's several
places where this stem from one of them
is the muster itself because guess what
the muster is great foundational
information it's a great foundational
leadership instruction that you're gonna
get when you go not everyone can make it
to the mustard so what we did is we took
the content from the first like two
musters that we did and this is the
fundamental principles from extreme
ownership from an academy leadership we
took those and put them into interactive
online training so that people that
couldn't make it to the muster could
still get that training we also did it
because companies that we work with
sometimes they have 10,000 employees
20,000 employees a hundred thousand
employees and all the employees are not
all in one place they're all over the
place they're all over the country and
they're all over the world
how we gonna train all those people we
what we needed to do is figure out a way
to scale the training that we did there
were many requests from the larger
companies we work with to get the
training to all their employees how do
we do that we had to scale it
we put it online and then once we put it
online for companies we figured okay
let's get it out there for direct to
consumers that want to take the training
they can't come to the muster what have
you or they want to get reminded what
they learned at the muster
same thing so that's online training
it's available now at EF online.com also
we've got EF overwatch where we are
taking leadership gaps in the civilian
sector and we are filling those
leadership gaps with trained and
experienced and tested leaders from
combat aviation and from a spec ops
community go to EF overwatch comm
regardless of which side of that
equation you're on whether you're a
company that needs leaders or whether
you're a a vet that's seeking a
leadership position in the company go to
EF / watch comm and fill out the
information that applies to you and if
you want to continue this conversation
with us we can be found all up in the
interwebs on Instagram on Twitter and on
the Facebook key bond echo is at Echo
Charles and I am at Jocko will Inc and
finally to all our military personnel
out there thank you for protecting
freedom around the world and to our
folks in uniform here at home police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs correctional officers border patrol
all first responders thanks for
protecting us and our families and to
everyone else out there
remember that discipline is stronger
than fury you need a little bit of fury
you need a little bit of discipline you
need to combine those things but you
take that discipline and you impose
discipline upon yourself and reject and
refuse delicate living and the luxuries
that are available to you in life and
instead get out
Comfort and make yourself better faster
smarter and stronger by going out there
day after day after day and getting
after it and until next time this is
echo and Jocko